now what are the concerns tied to the
coronavirus and all the job losses in
nevada it's just paying the bills the
state imposed a moratorium on evictions
during this emergency and on Friday
Governor Steve sis alike extended that
emergency for another month but critics
say tenants need more protection
Hector Mejia live this afternoon from
downtown Las Vegas where a demonstration
was held this morning Hector well the
group said they are thankful governor's
just like extended the eviction
moratorium until the end of the month
but they said they feel more could be
done for tenants we found a small group
out here outside the regional Justice
Center in downtown this morning the
group led by make the road Nevada
chanted things like canceled rent
according to one of the organizers some
tenants here in the valley are being
harassed some of them being singled out
for being immigrants they added this
demonstration is one of four happening
at the same time across the valley
they're shedding light on a number of
issues including better protections for
essential workers and with Nevada having
the highest unemployment rate in the
nation they said once that moratorium
expires it won't be that easy for
tenants to pay back any past due rent
payments so they are afraid tenants will
be kicked out to the streets once that
moratorium expires reporting from
downtown Hector Mejia 8 news now